so I only talk to the camera don't try
talking about fear dude nah you wake up
no breakfast and you do you hit your by
30 a steel horse
Papa's wake up ton 5:30 a.m. I hang out
with the kid oh yeah
the Papa rides okay cuz I have to say
it's getting on my last nerve this whole
riding guy dude the San Diego chapters
very strong what the senior what the San
Diego Chapter is very strong enough she
headed out there next Thursday you're
not in a [ __ ] you're not it's such a
biker gang don't say got your movement
don't they they go so San Diego Chapter
of the chapter the chapter of the thick
boy bike club yes the San Diego Chapter
it has just done I mean oh I'm Bob lost
for words I think this thing has gotten
and so say your loss for words it's the
Moose is so annoying and don't say I'm
but the movement yeah so oh use words
movement in Chapter please I'm begging
so Papa thick Thursday morning to drive
down to the San Diego Chapter your Papa
thick Papa thick so I'm gonna say what's
up to the finish wait I said now you're
going wind next Thursday why what's the
occasion you have great trails out there
and sell the Santa Cruz bike for me a
bike
so you're nine paddles you know I can't
trust other people's pedals well but
you're bringing your own pet only mount
helmet now your Papa's an EBE bike four
paddles are a thing
Oh big thing you gotta have your own
paddles you do you write clippings or
you you stand it
I would imagine I'm sander yeah we just
and it just depends on mountain bike
says if you fall I don't be a test of
the bike yeah now um I'm pretty excited
about this a bike coming because I was
making funny bikes and then the company
whitey said
lettuce anyone quit talking [ __ ] I went
bring it on gets delivered today
look I don't have to buy you one so you
still do because this one's not as good
as the one that I want what are you
talking about no no they're sending you
a probably a top of the line it's nice
it's great you know much is it don't
worry about me
what how much is it right six grand it's
a lot of money yeah it's great I guess
which a bunch of stuff out you know the
shots the restaurant now you're treating
your bikes like you do your cars yes now
you're treating your bikes you
you've already tricked out you've added
horsepower to your to it GTX you are -
it's being built right now GTX r2 is out
of this gt2 RS gt2 RS and you had to get
more horsepower yes that's be the best
so anyway so the San Diego Chapter I'm
excited to get out there and show faith
and just I can't anybody wants to ride
with us san diego's my life I can't do
like wouldn't kill you papa I'm not
doing it really my bike for you I just
feel like I can't draw did you get the
wind in your face feel snakes I mean
I'll go on another snake day yeah I'll
go for a rally yeah I thought you were
bullshitting me but you do see a lot of
snakes out there I stopped posting
because I see so many I saw one today I
stopped and I was like I'm gonna fill it
and post it again just to piss people
off well you know and the snake took off
Papa Papa wants to come with you
papa thin wants to come with you and I
will problem is Papa thin hurt his knee
yesterday and you saw that jumping I was
jumping I wanted to so bad but I thought
you know what well so hurt doing this
cuz then I miss my San Diego bike
chapter pants wait don't put chapters
above that but we were in we were
jumping on trampolines Brennan and I and
the best parkour woman in the world was
there achieve said do a front-flip and I
said to you don't do it I knew do it I
knew you were gonna do it I'll begin
doing you probably find problem is
sometimes you're not that weak a hammy
like what was I doing I was just trying
to jump over some foam in onto a mat per
my knee a little bit now my dad sent me
a pretty aggressive texts cuz I'm pretty
close to the snake I don't think you are
and I think you're fine you can see my
bike time what's your dad say
now stupidest I keep showing these
snakes now that a rattler yeah
watch watch that's Robin see I knew
you're gonna be like is that a rattler
watch ready here the rabble
I did hear you don't know snakes like me
bro you're not out there in the field
now I know you listen every day now now
there you are with your shirt off you
Bob is good and out there with a shirt
off getting after and getting lean yeah
you're a little leaner I'll be honest
with you my dude biking if I looked at
you from behind you're looking a little
leaner thanks dad
you're you're
more than 260 right now and that's
impressive you're right yeah look you're
looking good now Brian at 53 all
revealed a patient we're still reviewing
application it's tough man we're tough
stuff but hold onto some of the other
board members I'm getting a bit of a
belly I know I told you what we told you
this in Frank tell you my belly is both
agreed you're cutting in the belly I'm
getting a little belly well Frank has an
eight pack at fifty four shred City so I
am you guys you know belly what's going
on I go I don't know dude I was relaxed
my stomach was revealed does they don't
to say that and then you're you know
then you're kind of yeah
you're kind of good in that picture I'm
all traps I'm traps for days right there
dude how about I probably won my bet
with Rogan you know what so my buddy is
there right now in Long Beach Long Beach
he took that video so Deborah Newsome
for you guys I don't know to see you I
decide to try and banned all beaches
they went all right my back because
there's a huge opera uproar cuvette all
right just Orange County very strange -
there's so many beaches they did just
Orange County Republican place whatever
not strange at all so he's like I'm just
gonna ban or Orange County beaches and
the people are having it and Rogan sends
out just like yo dude no way they're
shutting down the beaches he goes dude
it's law I went I guarantee you people
aren't gonna obey that law you don't
realize how little power government you
don't really have to listen well no we
just show it you can show it because
this is actually not on Instagram this
is actually what what's going on right
now in Long Beach because they shut down
the beaches
well Rogan did say I hope you're right
yeah well listen man I mean I think that
we're not the only ones feeling fed up
with this oh dude on the trail today
someone one of the bikers one of my bike
bros coming down shoutout thick voice
but he is coming down and goes dude
there's a cop up top giving tickets yo
hey for what yes for being on trail yo
they never safe never shut these trails
they could easily close them off there's
nothing when we give tickets for music I
don't know it's the I sauce don't give
someone a ticket so now as I'm biking up
I have these thoughts in my head I'm
gonna just dismantle verbally this cop I
mean couldn't they couldn't they just
say trails are only open to people
buycks because you're not biking
together and wave beats they're only
open to surfers
I mean you could be more tactical issues
of thing dum-dums
we all know proven fact yes son kills
the virus it does so on you're gonna ban
beaches and outdoor parts but then
you're gonna allow people to go into
grocery stores because essential stuff
but yeah mental happiness mental case
the idea though the trails are small and
people can look up with six feet apart
but a lot of X trails are no so a lot of
people I can Topanga instead all you do
is wet it so if you're that big of a
[ __ ] you just wait and let the people
won now how do you I know it's insane
I know what ok this courses now what do
you notice about this what do you notice
is anybody wearing a mask no one's
wearing a mask Pete you said it people
are fed up with it this is Long Beach
beside the beach I'm a scientist
now they're on their last leg so now
it's a wool there's more cases every day
well we're testing more you have to wear
masks only protects 2% of it really of
anything coming in 2% that's the biggest
thing is the guard the government
because they didn't know a lot of stuff
they just haven't been clear so you just
keep they just keep generally saying
spouts that my Newsom's over the top
because he's so Democrat so he's trying
to [ __ ] with everything you know so it's
very strange it's it's really but there
but there are a lot of parts of the
world like like him cry and standardized
by Jean did the lockdown was so real
there that they because they had open
borders with Iran they got big it got
hit with it so you have to text the
government and the government will give
you a code and you can go out for 30
minutes and then the cops have to see
that text on your Australia has a
shutdown where they the cops come by the
house is make sure nobody's outside make
sure you're inside it's it's a testament
to America that Americans are like hey
listen now yes I understand this country
was a risk mine that we're gonna show up
to your house yeah it's interesting it's
really interesting I'm a lot of
Americans just get they start to go I
got to get back to work dude it's tough
I don't know yeah I don't know we got
that the bottom line is that after the
h1n1 thing you should have a second girl
we should have been ready and we know
what I want to do to you got cut with
our caught with our pants down yeah and
and is there a now a chapter or is it
just you the LA chapter is the biggest
chapter Papa she was created in LA huh
it's international though alright don't
you see my Instagram's man I don't watch
the Australian oh yeah Iran Iraq South
Korea I didn't see anything I didn't see
sapphire later on you can see a rocking
around all over yeah
Thailand that's some big dumb thick girl
and not in Thailand
I think it's Thailand there's a big old
girl on the bike really she can I have
you know I guess still revered in that
position what what do you have to do
what is the criteria when you look at my
application what are you looking at what
ask can't be in the club wait what one
of the things that might disc
so you say there's a chance I could I
could have my I could be disqualified
barred from entering yeah dude
there's a chance I mean who's doing more
like you know what you're looking at
more likely than wait so you're the guy
so what are you what is the criteria you
know me why can't I be part of the thick
boy bike club now I'll be the thin boy
representative just not you get injured
all the time you don't commit it I don't
get injured all the time I'm pretty
injury free big one he's gotta own a
bike well you said you'd get me one no
you get Papa you gotta buy me the bike
for stealing all those years yeah but
other people have been I'm sure their
people reach out we'll hook you up with
a bike I've already had that huh don't
look at that is that your bike yeah
now is that a trick sound chopper comp
carbon body so the whole body's Carmen
ah very like those are Fox 34 is in the
front I'd prefer 36 like a little
stiffer this is 34 twin custom path yes
what the [ __ ] is a milder lizard-skin
grips up top in the kangaroo oh my god
so wait what is the what is this
[ __ ] what is the [ __ ] what 17 34
and 36 those are wheels we equals huh oh
man I can't do that it's just stupid I
can't man no you [ __ ] idiot I don't
know these little details
he said the forks shocks to the Lehman's
so the 34s would be that it's the it's
been on my garden the width so you can
get bigger ones so 36 well papa 58 they
just made a 40 but that's all for
downhill
I see cuz you need you have a lot of
ways I'm just I I like going downhill
I'm really enjoying the uphills me could
you be the biggest mountain biker in the
world you think I don't possibly there's
some big boys on there but y'all like my
Instagram stories some thick kids really
oh yeah they're mainly doing on the
streets you know why see your stories
you good trails makes I raise you three
beers what's a [ __ ] so the the the rouse
takes our official mascot I don't know
we just came out with that press that's
a big boy right there
where
right there thickest [ __ ] that dentist
I'm just tired some lady proposed to a
picture of her riding crashing it's
hilarious I don't think it's on anymore
bunch of sheep sheep let me see the
Bears what the [ __ ]
how's he not let's Aspen that's Alaska
when I say worldwide movement Brian
we're all over that's a fake boys bike
club it's walking on ice Sears now if
you see car maybe no mames around Mama's
there yeah mama that's Vegas downtown
they blast that new Drizzy do you know
what Drizzy is [ __ ] do I know trizzie do
you know what he did do you know what he
did and that's why you're not in the
club No drusy that's what you know I
know he's all like what the [ __ ]
now that's me now it's out there Bubba
let's go I get bit by something it's
trouble right my ride in the middle of
the path you know middle of nowhere how
great is that thought I'd be out there
makes it worth now for your chapter that
California Chapter hoodies being sent
out let you consent to the troops oh
there I am and that's from bites and
bears huge by Club are you holding a pie
I'm holding up pumpkin pie that's why I
ride my bike now you're on your palace
in there and door but I would touch my
Pelt on this a lot bought my bike I
don't touch it
no get outdoors day comes have victims a
lot of pictures buddy oh there's the San
Diego Chapter all right well they are
out together okay we're taking the
screws e-bikes I see Santa Cruz makes a
nice bike and they're on the ebike so
that means they can make goat assist
that's pretty cool that's what's getting
to live to that guy and if I can that a
lot the ebike you would like I promise a
little bit that's why I go so early how
great is that
that's amazing DOS Brack did that made
me way too thick oh my god that's good
though yeah apparently Eric Griffin I'm
all of this [ __ ] huh yeah who's the dog
oh that's his dog I'll do it
Marshall
any location Eddie looks Asian they just
so how I think that's right did he does
location only cool and then that picture
is uh Jamie in the back you got planned
this weekend what you got planned this
week you know get the ebike going gonna
put that together by taking about an
hour twenty been watching videos online
how to put together my take my son out
to those trails what recommend it why
too much take it up would be a beast for
it follow really yeah huh
okay better to be on a road if you
haven't done it yeah I'd be a little bit
of yeah could you mean to get up and
ride you mean it cuz it could just go
you're just gonna hike it you'd hike it
yeah I could I want to show them on
don't want some rattlesnakes and stuff
it's kind of cool
yeah you gotta go really far for the
rattle things you do you're not ready
again that's why you're Nanak so you're
out there how many miles out there you
buy about eight miles up top going up by
the time you see sir so you're going
uphill mm-hmm Papa's in some shape you
know you don't know I went I'm gonna
bring your son the first not too much I
don't bring my son anymore
come around snakes Jesus yeah I gotta I
gotta see what the [ __ ] that trails
about that looks really cool I love that
that's how I write when I go out there
I've written a lot of stand up out there
you don't write a lot just around him
huh you look less they went on those
trails well I'd go up to trails new
Topanga but I walk them with less than
one of the trails in Topanga four days
ago five days ago no no no no I'm sorry
two weeks ago you're lying come on it
was before they closed the trails but
the two-week doot to pain was closed way
way before to eat like let me thank you
live because I write three weeks ago
help to veins been closed since we
started the quarantine let me thank Kahn
what I say first time you said three
days ago which I went to last week it
was a live two weeks huh and now it's
been have we been like Courtney before
five weeks ago four weeks ago nope
that's still not true either that's only
you know like five weeks ago I would say
is when I last time I was on the trails
it's all right man
this is why you're not in the club no
come on let me be the club man did I did
I told a little lie
yeah cop pretty hard dude six weeks ago
I was on the trail what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know why now I'm gonna court of law
he's gotta be all detailed what's the
difference if I got my coffee six weeks
I wanted to be coffee you know a lot the
biker owned tends to be coffee biker own
it's the name ten-speed yeah I know I
know dude I'm done with this bike
culture [ __ ] man
dude joy has birthdays on Tuesday but
her friends threw a surprise birthday
this morning oh I'm sounds trails but
one of her friends brought over this
cake that someone made in the valley at
the store and it's a strawberry
strawberry bundt cake with a homemade
icing on [ __ ] I've been good on my diet
man yeah that's funny and eating green
oh good news everybody this week on it
has 25% off all their supplements from
alpha brain alpha brain instant you got
new mood melatonin spray you got
problems with you got they got total gut
health protein powder
dude the protein powder creatine 25% off
and I know a lot of you boys playing at
quarantine 15 shred that wait man let on
it helped 25% off this week only go two
on it calm slash fighter an additional
10% off and then they're given twenty
five percent off supplements he say what
35 what planet.com slash fighter I think
what do they do with horses when they
die you know wrench the French horses
aren't any of a donkey they still eat
horses oh yeah I think certain places in
Asia like Japan still for sure they
don't still make no Huff's do they I
feel like you come up with better ways
to make blue I know that in uh oh my god
my my wife my ex-wife who rides she knew
a person who that's paid some crazy
amount of money for a jumper some crazy
amount of money like I don't know what's
a jumper like a socialist I mean
literally 200 or so is that like two
hundred thousand dollars
more right for this course very special
like Olympic you know like and well that
horse went missing and they found that
horse about two miles down the way in a
field and it had been butchered for its
meat yeah they these people were poor in
the area and they just killed that horse
and [ __ ] took it had no idea that I
was a regular horse though probably yes
that's a torn if that's not a horse then
they ended no they ate that day Dave
they have me for the next year 1200
pound animal makes sense if you're
starving or you're hungry or a half
horse I've never been anywhere I've
actually eaten horse in France was it
nice it was dried they dry it and slice
it and she said you know what you're
eating and I said what she goes horse
meat we eat everything else
it's it's a hoofed animal you would eat
him out in a wild believe me they
probably taste like elk look at that
it's pretty [ __ ] fresh yeah chin you
would [ __ ] eat that I would yeah have
you tried only if it was like you know
of course a horse is gonna die or
something like that but I wouldn't want
to eat it normally I would but if it was
at a restaurant to eat a cow yes he
honest if I was at a restaurant they
served it and it was it was done well
you know I mean it was taken care of
yeah yeah because what happens with a
lot of horses when they can't jump
anymore when you buy a horse for a lot
of money and then they are you retire
them well you still put him out to
pasture and they still have to live in a
stable but they live their life in a
field eating like horses do and then
they die but that costs some money
sometimes you still have vet bills yes
[ __ ] you did well I told you how much
you don't like you could have I said you
said you Bugatti
yeah you said what do you want it would
I pick whatever car you want to drive
what do you pick one I saw the bill for
how much was it dude yeah you said that
you like pick one pick what car what car
it looks pretty nice I know dude who
spends for his wife's horse habit and I
call it a habit he spends I think five
hundred thousand dollars a year on
horses just horses do they even know
them though oh yeah and if you put the
horses on another it's not in there
pretty you get a drive to program they
told him correct so you cannot really
Lisa them well no but you you own them
what happens is they day then you have
to pay a groomsman yeah a groom my groom
isn't a groom you have to pay stable fee
you have to pay vet bills you got all
kinds of [ __ ] all kinds of weird stuff
such a and then they have such a rich
person and they have to be exercised
they have to be exercised I knew a guy
that did the horseshoes that's his
business
oh yeah he was making oh yank oh yeah a
shitload of change of shoes yes the best
the best is anytime you have an industry
like that with people who have a lot of
money you have smart people who come in
and say I'm a horse chiropractor like
this family that's a bummer have I paid
for it
oh no maybe I have Brendan now fight my
belt did I take my bath I'm going how
much pick your battles II don't know but
it sure was
Wow more than that but come on dude she
or he has got a crack the horses you've
got to get the horse into place there's
all kinds of [ __ ] that goes on with
horses and it's not just that they you
know there's also magnets some do magnet
there all kinds let their horses Brian
yes they do but this yes they do but
they're also people that do weird [ __ ]
like this they do like magnetic therapy
oh you know it's bro science all those
all those things like cupping you have
on your like they have too much money so
they're like yeah I'll do all kinds of
stuff put antennas on my horse sure did
we showed this on blow the belt in Pico
bring up his and scam if he goes like
check out because he rides rides rides
horses there's no more horses and he's
supposed to videos force doing like a
dance
well Tennessee Walking Horse yeah
whatever yes so the problem is is the
horse is a you said Tennessee Walking
Horse I might be I said yeah you don't
know here's a giant black dick up giant
black oh sure but there you go hey hey
and for sure don't pose him like hey
checking my horse dancing and then not
much not a giant in the video look at
this thing slapping his thighs so what
he's doing right now is dressage
that's a dick that's really hard to do
see what he's doing he's he's an
excellent writer that's dressage I grew
up riding yeah
that's a that's a that's a towards the
end that massive calm happen yeah it
goes all the way around his leg yeah it
does that's a dick I like that he just
ignores the dick oh that's [ __ ] genes
you know he's not like what a [ __ ]
stud he can ride horses to [ __ ] where'd
he grow up where is he from
it's from California mm-hmm relax let
loose it's Friday stay safe in the fam
love you
relax worse is real relax like let loose
that black dick slap in the back of his
thigh that's a white horse with a black
dick I appreciate that
that thing is impossible that's crazy
that's [ __ ] it oh yeah mr. hands to
drop Chris I told two o'clock cause he
called us or week on him chin let's do
it sounds good all right hey Chris the
quarantine they won't let you out of the
house to see a barber nothing huh now
dude I got [ __ ] nothing going on I
got not well no next week starting next
week my boy step four now shadow
pronounced hair so on dirt out with Bay
Ridge he's gonna start doing haircuts he
legally out of his garage so you know
it's like he just blew his cover I feel
like that is over now oh yeah a part out
you did I said hello to you and you you
you got you started kissing the mic
which is inappropriate yeah cuz let me
tell you something I'm [ __ ] horny
right now yeah and I'm looking at those
ankles and Brendan's me and I want to
get some coconut peanut butter on that
look that off alright well I don't even
know what coconut peanut butter is man
you gotta calm down any any brave ladies
in New York willing to come over and
hang out no it's nothing that just a
bunch of dudes so far it's no there's
been nothing no I've been I've been you
know just kind of dude I mean look at
this last time I came on your show in
the beginning of March you know Brian's
like listen guy you know great stories
just gonna be huge for you I see big
things in the future there the pandemic
hits an out doing [ __ ] zoom
for my daughter's bedroom I know it's
not a bit listen this is throwing us off
for a little bit of a [ __ ] loop
sometimes you get thrown for a loop
sometimes you you get you know what I
mean they go you got to make a left down
here and wait you gotta sit in this
holding pattern I'm about a cup we're
all about to take off our bottoms to a
spread sprout wings now we got to sit in
the [ __ ] holding your it's bad
hunkers New York is really it's actually
really bad I feel like in LA I mean I
know you guys got cases but I'm in New
York you know everyone's dying you know
and people guys yeah what a lot of
people died and it's crazy yep because
like you can't you know I know you guys
are doing well with your you know
podcasts and your you know and
everything but like in New York you know
you couldn't pay me enough to get in the
same room as a Chinese and I know you
guys are in there with an Asian Chris
you can't look like I gotta just be very
cat is from Vietnam and and and cheers
is of South Korea merit Chinese I know
but you said Asian and that you said you
wouldn't be a room with 280 little
nervous that's a little racist dude so
I'm gonna have to but you would get a
little nervous Chris why is that racist
I mean I don't want to get the [ __ ]
wool hand Weiser alright that's Chinese
people from blue hand goddamn it Chris
please don't love yeah all Asian I think
guy I don't [ __ ] know man I'll just
you know I'll just take a beat for
broccoli what do you let me tell you
that's not I don't know I don't know
what I want you to tell you that not to
be so stereotypical it's important to
these times to understand that viruses
don't discriminate you know what I'm
saying well ya know what what do you do
I mean honestly man you know I got I got
my daughter I got a four-year-old
daughter so it's everyday it's just
unlike preschool stuff with her I do my
podcast I got my podcast history of
hyenas I do our every morning I'm doing
a morning show called wet by in the
morning on our patreon patron calm slash
Bay Ridge Boys myself and Yanis Papa's
Yanni the Greek we've been doing that
every day talking about the stories and
you know that's what I do and I try to
go for jog but I'm getting fat I
unfortunately um Krissy cusps I'm right
on the cusp of getting hit my tits back
I'm trying it's just they're they're
starting to fluff up a little bit like
that's a TAS I got a fat lunch lady ass
with fat thighs it's hard not to hear
it's hard not to eat a lot yeah man
eating and just sitting around in New
York I mean it's scary cuz everybody
everybody knows somebody who's sick or
died it's like 9/11 in New York where
everybody knew somebody and that was
only 3,000 people not only that was
3,000 people this is 1520 thousand
deaths in New York so it's gets to the
point where you're just like I mean what
what am I do well every day all I do is
I put off my gloves my mask and I wrap
myself in the American flag and I walk
outside and I'm protected okay I don't
know about the American flag I I
appreciate a patriotism I have a very
important question before we get to
patriotism the American flag you don't
ask for years old you're in a room is
there a reason you painted her wall a
bad wing there's a bat wing it splits
bat wing blocking out the light it's
badly like no oh wait there's a bat wing
well below you
oh no because that's that's the
construction that's just the UM we did
like a chalk like a soft wing for her
room so yeah I [ __ ] up wait let me let
me see what are you guys talking about
exactly
hey hey Chris Chris you know we're
[ __ ] pants and you tucked your dog
you gotta you got a month a man [ __ ]
I got a but yeah I I just wanted to see
what you guys meant it's uh that wasn't
appropriate dude nobody asked you to do
that what dude I can't have a [ __ ] for
quarantine I know you can i I've been
telling Brian for weeks now this
quarantines make me real gay dude yeah a
guy I want to crawl through the [ __ ]
hole in your jeans and go to town you
scrotum you [ __ ] homo Hey well
alright that's aggressive to your you're
gonna love to change right now I need
you to calm man you're coming in hot
Chris girls I'm Chrissy quarantine I'm
cooped up Chrissy kind of just up for
this [ __ ] already hey can you still
order delicious New York food or are
they shut down - no absolutely can order
you could order a [ __ ] order delicious
food you know and then I they just can't
come within six feet of your door so I
got like a little rake look and then
they they call me on outside and then
tell them to put the uh put the food on
the rake and then I take it in and then
if
give me any lip I [ __ ] take their
legs out with the rake and get the [ __ ]
off my property that's crazy talk
well so what are you guys a lot of you
guys are not able to make a living at
all it's good right tough I mean we know
a lot of comics who live paycheck to
paycheck yeah yeah no I know a lot of
those guys I saw them in Central Park
eating pigeons oh there's nothing I can
really do about you know those guys I
mean that's what they want to do I mean
they're putting their stock in doing
spots in New York City and Rylan are
people doing podcast it's like well now
you're eating the vermin on the street
because you know I'm on patreon here
make it real [ __ ] money and you're
over there you know telling me I'm not a
good comment because I wasn't past the
Comedy Cellar well now how do me a favor
eat a [ __ ] raccoon turn because yeah
there's no nobody it's really hard for
most most of my peers right they're
happy making any money but thank God we
got podcast thank God for the patreon
you know and we're still able I'm still
able to make money and then I applied on
a couple loan applications about gotten
some all loans that are illegal so
that's not that's crazy and you have
small business like you haven't it taken
to selling your month yet have you no
I'm not selling my month yet but I will
absolutely do that if thing goes into
the summertime
I'm absolutely down to sell my month
whatever what is uh what is your boy
saying is he saying they're gonna
stretch this into the summer cool
Governor Cuomo yeah yeah now that that's
the only Democrat that I'd ever vote for
I mean that guy he's an Italian kid
that's just you know I mean there's
brothers his brother's a soccer mom Oh
Luke we got a deal with his brother
Chris Cuomo on CNN it's like you know
he's a martyr all of a sudden it's like
shut up and take your shirt off guy it's
like I know why you did the broadcast
with his shirt on that's what I do yell
at the TV all the time you know and but
Andrew Cuomo I think he's doing an
excellent job he [ __ ] Mayor Bill
DeBlasio
instills a lot of fear Governor Cuomo
says hey things are gonna be okay here's
and gives us a plan so the governor
though has said Connecticut has just
said today that they're gonna open up
May 20th and Governor Cuomo said
anything Connecticut or New Jersey does
that's what New York's gonna do we're
like all in solidarity so I'm hoping
that it opens it up at least phase one
opening May 20th all right yeah the only
thing como [ __ ] up well
one thing he really [ __ ] up on when it
was when cases started to pop up so she
in the old folks home
he went if you're not showing symptoms
or you're not really sick
don't go the hospital stained the old
folks home so most the deaths start in
the old folks home
yeah a lot of people died for us it's
it's all about the subway it's like
that's the only difference between you
know our city and LA and Chicago and
whatever it's just the subway I mean at
my daughter's Godfather's an emergency
room doctor and he said especially in
the beginning and in late March early
April and that it was like peak peak he
said nearly 100% of the patients that
came in that were not elderly that were
in their 40s or 50s they all took the
subway and they all that that was like
the main carrier so do they outfit they
all have bodies like a lunch lady huh
did they all have bodies like a lunch
lady
they all had lunch lady assets yeah well
that dude he told me he was like you
know the he's seeing the people who are
young who come in with corona and have
bad results they all got high blood
pressure and [ __ ] and fat asses and
that's what I got you got do you have
high blood pressure I do I got a little
HBP but it's only high blood pressure
when and like because I get so nervous
and worked up that they'll take my blood
pressure will be through the roof yeah
but then as I calm down I just watch you
know like I watch videos I watch like
the you know United States winning the
war in Vietnam and I do things like that
I'm down all right it goes way down my
god you say you're your baby you're
still the [ __ ] enemy to me Chitti no
see now again you're making this about
in Asia you're making this easy
Asia whitening and I have to stop you
there you just can't do that you're
bringing up Vietnam cats from she's
Vietnamese but she's American
please be selective please be sensitive
to to the people that work with us Sidra
I'm sorry yeah yeah yeah I'm [ __ ]
yeah I guess when I start my podcast up
again I go to the studio I'm just gonna
hire a bunch of Muslim women because
they're already way the mess why did
they think it's been Corona since before
Christ all right well I don't know if
that's true either I don't think her own
is the reason they wear these they wear
their they cover their faces god dammit
Chris please try to be a little more
sensitive to our ethnic brothers and
sisters out there we're yeah watch the
[ __ ] Goldberg's on ABC that's about
Jews so let's all let's all
you know and that's all love love each
other yeah absolutely I mean I'm staring
right at [ __ ] right at Brendan's and
he's got nice tight jeans on and he's
got just nice [ __ ] thigh lips well
you know what it is dude he's behind any
bikes he's a serious mountain biker now
he bikes home yeah and Brian you look
like a sphinx cat like you leaning I'm
leaning up and I've been working out I
appreciate that pal hey know what start
off with North Korea guys think kim
jeong-hoon is dead what do you guys
think he's deader than a [ __ ] door
now I don't think yeah I think I think
it's all [ __ ] you think it's all
[ __ ] yeah he's a five wonder I
wonder if he's [ __ ] dead or not I
don't know what is what are the what is
what is chin think Jen and cath you guys
think he's dead we don't why are you
asking them for Christ you know my
parents told me that uh they saw this
before back in the day with his father
come Jonah's father yeah so he hid away
for a while came back later and I'm chin
sir parents age so I know this Hey hey
Chris what are you watching right now in
quarantine dude give me something shows
I started watching the last Kingdom on
Netflix I loved the Vikings I've been
watching the Viking I watch the Vikings
on the History Channel and I watch the
last king I'm watching the last Kingdom
now I watched all the Marvel movies in
order I watched unorthodox about a suit
of Jewish laminated skates I mean I
watched the first few episodes I thought
I thought it was Moshe kasher who's
playing the lead but it's some other
girl i watch that and then and then what
else
I mean Tiger King of course I watched
Tiger King I watched that too early and
then you know a bunch of Barbie [ __ ]
that my daughter wants to watch okay
that's pretty much it what about you
guys I got really into this show on
Amazon hunters with Al Pacino with a-rod
Nazis in New York in the 70s it's [ __ ]
yeah it's great but based off a great
literally the bakery in my neighborhood
I grew up in Ridgewood Queens and it's a
old-school German neighborhood and the
bakery in my neighborhoods been there
since 1910 they catered the sweets and
desserts for the biggest Nazi rally in
America in 1938 at Madison Square Garden
they're the ones that gave the freaking
lives its hearts and all the cookies to
that oh wow
yeah are you still out there protesting
I know you're a champion of the Jews I
love did you I love Jewish people I'm
circumcised myself I love Jewish
people they're actually getting in
trouble in Brooklyn because they're
still going out having funerals and
events amongst the corona of mire stuff
so like I worry that the anti-semitism
is gonna it's gonna like you know topple
because it sucks cuz it's like I don't
know I think I try to do it's like it's
like you know for me it's like these
people like fine whatever they want to
do is up to them I just go I Drive by if
I ever see like a Orthodox funeral I
Drive by I just throw ham and cheese
sandwiches happen and then they use very
well okay see again I think that's a
very racist thing to do and here how is
that racist well your acting is that
you're throwing pork at very religious
people and I think that would be
offensive to Muslims Jews and frankly to
me as well just because you don't be
throwing ham and cheese you threw it ham
and cheese sandwich at me
I would try to flag you down and punch
you in the face I'm just saying again I
have my hands full I have my ass well
you're a big sturdy kid yeah it's just
it works two ways what I do is I Drive
around with the cooler full of ham and
cheese sandwiches and it go I break up I
break up any Hasidic Jewish funerals or
events that are going on cuz I don't
want them to get sick from Corona I was
good put their mask on so I draw that
and then I continue driving it to my
head and I throw ham and cheese outside
the comedy clubs and all the comedians
come out and scurry off the steps and I
can see them and because ham cheese and
squab or raccoon goes well with it goes
well Chris have you seen what's going on
on out here in LA there's straight-up
protests like at the beach and stuff
what because people want to you're
saying Juana the lockdown to be over
Heather yeah California it's [ __ ]
done with it man well I get it because
it's like you guys really you know based
off your population don't really have
that many cases and deaths I think your
governor did a great job of closing down
the state early enough and control what
he can control so we kind of feel I get
I get if I was living in California I'd
be like you know it feels like the
problems happening
3,000 miles away which you know kind of
is but then I understand how it can
spread very rapidly you guys are doing
better like yeah like even coma came out
and said that you guys peaked a while
ago it's going down there's no joy in
New York there's really no choice I mean
you can't you know I mean it got flow I
mean there's people there's bodies in
the back of u-haul trucks outside
funeral homes so you can't
there's no other choice here I think
even now though I've noticed like over
the past like two or three weeks like
you'll see people come out more and more
and more without masks without gloves
you're starting to see people walking
around more I mean in late March I mean
on my corner there were like army trucks
driving up and down the block well that
is not that I shake hands and hug oh
you're here right now I'm fine I would
lick your [ __ ] face Chris I don't you
look funny how speak like it's a what
form of defiance like I don't get talked
about Khurana come over here I'm not
gonna change my I'm not gonna change my
behavior in my life in a sort of like
people get are so wary of it sure well
yeah I mean yesterday I went to the
doctor's office when I got an antibody
test a corona antibody test cuz I was
like I'm sure I've gotten it even if I
didn't have symptoms and it was a
negative it was a negative test was one
of the only times I got a negative test
and was happy about it I understand yeah
but I still got a drip baby are you
writing are you are you who are you
writing right now are you writing what'd
you say honey bubbles no no don't call
me that man I'm not comfortable with
honey bubbles
now what about tortellini too if she
like that all like tortellini porcini
that's - no no I don't like these things
you have to call me Brian why do I like
you got a nice little shaped head I mean
you're [ __ ] you look good baby got a
nice little pump yeah I got a pump I do
all right I mean I trained I trained I
know days off you know what I'm saying
no dude yeah absolutely so what what you
say chicken no you can't call me a
chicken you're objectifying man and it's
everyone nature Christa you're honest
you guys get together and do the podcast
or you guys he does it from the hall
from there no because he honest is our
wife is pregnant now she's I think about
four months pregnant now so you know you
can't their research is not you know you
don't want to go around a pregnant woman
because who knows what happens you know
in the early stages of gestation like
that so we just do it you know over zoom
just like this and that's just I mean
really besides my family I mean I
haven't seen anybody and that's most of
you are people we haven't seen each
other since you know March 12th or
something like that because it's just
too risky
that's crazy guy who would have seen
this coming these no knowings nobody I'm
I mean none of us we're all making jokes
about it like people are posting jut
like forthcoming the last days at the
Comedy Cellar we'll all just like
posting jokes about you know coronavirus
and how it's you know not Seattle's
problem or China's problem and then
literally three days later the streets
are closed so it came up on a squid but
I think the good news is is that they
keep talking about the second wave
doctor foul a little sweet doctor doctor
out she found she keeps talking about
the second way and I and I think we're
gonna be so much more well prepared for
it now because we're taking it seriously
because the first one that little squeak
got on and started telling us about the
corona virus we're like where's this
guy's [ __ ] stepstool
who is this guy I want to take him my
duffel bag I mean I was I was you know I
was watching his this this little squeak
doctor come on I'm like it's just one of
my daughter's classmates I mean who the
[ __ ] is this guys the squeak it does a
little baby guy yelling at us but now I
really listen to him and I'm a disciple
of dr. funky okay good oh wow wow yeah
my only this is a profile cheese he
never comes up with any he never has any
ideas or a plan just me and he likes to
exaggerate he likes to say things like
you know a lot of people like maybe
maybe 300,000 they said what do you
think and what do you think of this what
do you think of this because I'm just
trying to think you know you guys are
Hollywood I'm trying to think Hollywood
mind so we think of this we get the
movie that comes out pandemic 2020 one
gets two years we fund that we got
doctor foul chew we got him played by
Joe Pesci
we got Martin Scorsese directing it we
got Donald Trump we'll have him play by
Alec Baldwin and then for the
coronavirus I was thinking we have that
play by Bobby Lee what do you think hold
on do it again I mean I don't think I
don't want Bobby Lee die again I'm
taking a fence a little bit because both
of these Korean he's really American and
you want him to play a virus I mean I
want to get this Chris now because I
just because the virus they say is a
little virus and I you know he's shorter
guy no no patient zero maybe now maybe
pills on stage
nope no pills on time oh I don't like
this I don't like this movie what about
Ronny Chang oh nope seed again here no
but there's you're you're focusing on
the wrong thing
I'm
I'm saying funny comedians that that
kill you know to plate the Krone about
her so Bobby Lee or Ronny Chang or
Margaret Cho no there's a no I'm just no
you tonight it's a woman okay she's a
woman you're talking about all of these
people are Korean I have a gang again
and you're lumping in Koreans with
Chinese I already find that offensive
and I'm gonna have to ask you to two
maybe maybe suggest a white guy to play
the virus just on Clues I would say
quarantines made him a little racist but
he was like this before here because
turn you now a bit of a racist I'm just
kidding around I hope the fans I'm just
kidding as I said at the first time I'm
one of the bigger I have the biggest
transgender fan base from any podcast
and now we tried it we tried to verify
that Chris and we really couldn't see
any as hard to find stats on that right
stats on that dude cuz I got a [ __ ]
months I just showed you you don't think
you don't think that it's Oh your pants
still down my yeah they're always yeah
you're in your daughter's room she's
four and you don't have the decency to
wear pants Chris I mean I got whatever
Barbie dolls in my ass right now it
matter now that that spreads that's Reds
kovat or pink a well or allegedly pink I
think I know I'm just I'm just kidding
around yeah no quarantine I've been
cooped up Chrissy but I you know yeah
I'm just
it's like one of these things where it's
like you know you tried to comedy over
this film and then sometimes it doesn't
connect and then you just look like
really alright so sorry
that's a virus Chris it might be your
behavior for Christ I'm just kidding no
guys I'm obviously I'm just kidding I
hope everyone's alright I know we loved
one stay safe and Nancy Pelosi created
the corona virus you can't convince me
otherwise
it's very insidious signing off on a
nice note I mean yeah how about giving
us something positive before you leave
with some positive me here's a positive
note it's Friday
you know it's Friday it's give us some
hope Friday saying you might be guest of
the year man Wow that's [ __ ] crazy I
know I really appreciate that I
hopefully hopefully it's me but yes
something positive I mean I got you know
I'm trying to bring the laugh
sir on every day like I said we got that
morning show wet by in the morning for a
spanish-speaking audience we do the show
in English so you know but the sweatbox
Spanish but that's on patreon.com so
hold on it's a spit you're saying it's a
Spanish show but you do it in English so
I'm not sure this because you call it
wet pilot since then yeah what swept up
me speaking well I don't know what it
means but it's weapon in the morning or
if you're watching with your kids what
be throw in the morning idea do you
speak Spanish Chris I don't speak
Spanish but you know along with the
transgender fanbase we also have we
learned that we also have one of the
biggest Spanish speaking fan bases out
there so we said to give back to them
we're gonna do a morning show in Spanish
about Tom Segura does a podcast in
Spanish so we need to do that too
following Tom Segura footsteps so we
made the morning show which is available
on patreon.com slash very rich boys Wepa
in the morning what it is in English and
that day can translate to Spanish in
their homes because this is the red
white and blue bed we speak English
language is Chris you can get a Chris
that's inclusive we care because we have
a diverse audience it could you be a
little more inclusive with your message
well dami Moscow so Lina will be more
inclusive with with the map with my
message I just want to say yeah I hope
um I hope everyone out there is
listening to the rules socially
distancing six feet apart we're all
gonna get through this together getting
your masks on getting your gloves on
keep your hands clean
you know there's virus it is not China's
fault Chinese Americans have nothing to
do with this do not take anything out on
them on Asian people they have nothing
to do with this we're all in this
together
but you know as long as you're going
outside with the American flag draped
around you at the plane blasting Bruce
Springsteen I think you're fine okay now
that's again the American yeah it's
pretty American it's pretty American
it doesn't have to be Springsteen that's
pretty it doesn't have to be Springsteen
it it doesn't have to be Bruce
Springsteen at all you can just you can
people you can play the national anthem
whatever you guys want what about a
little
Terrica it's pretty America there you go
Metallica Metallica's good whoever you
want whoever whatever you want to do um
but listen we're all we're all in this
together but you know this is really I
mean it's New York City's problem right
I mean I know other states are trying to
jump in and be like era where we have
cases to shut up okay bring your stuff
to New York or I'll [ __ ] die in here
and it's just pretty bad okay I mean I
cut my dick off and sold it on the
streets and give my family something to
eat tonight so this I mean I don't care
about what your problems are I will shut
up and give us your money
Jesus Christ man things must be bad it
must be very bad - Stefano you you have
been using your dick much huh or have
you been well no I haven't been the
Brendan what's in that Cup is that your
urine I'd like to I'd like to purchase
that oh it's whiskey buddy
Brendan drinks in the middle of the day
Oh weird dude I gotta be on the story
I've been becoming like a full-fledged
alcoholic with myself I mean every day
I'm drinking Pinot Grigios and beers I'm
doing everything I did crystal meth the
other night all right steady I know I
know because I'm just sitting inside
it's like what am I supposed to do you
know I want to just do anything what
time it isn't glue time what time does
baby girl go to sleep what times before
you go to sleep seven so yeah I mean
quarantine with the four-year-old it's
rough Bubba's it's a little brutes
Macoutes even though she's my best
friend I love her so much I mean she's
you know we're past the stages with naps
so she doesn't see naps anymore Papa's
old you know she wakes up every day 7:30
in the morning she goes to bed 9 10
o'clock at night and it's a hundred
miles an hour all day every day but you
know the silver lining is I'm spending
so much time at there you know all this
time that I would have been on the road
and all that I'm with her so it's
beautiful and that even that looks you
know a little inside comedy I don't know
how you guys feel about this but this
whole pandemic in quarantine has been
making me rethink the road it's like do
I want to go to some city to sit there
for four days and deal with whatever
[ __ ] deal a comedy club wants to
give when I can be you know doing the
podcast making money and taking care of
my own family not messing things up my
daughter yeah it's made any recent
career stuff a little yeah yeah I think
anybody who doesn't grow from this
lockdown is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anybody who doesn't reconsider things
and kind of take things into perspective
I mean what do you do
yeah yeah no I know I bet I've been
growling I've been doing a lot of you
know I've been reading a lot of been
reading I'm reading a book on John Adams
right now I was write a book on the
Civil War been reading a lot about that
over a lot about the history and about
how Chinese been controlling us for a
long time and it's just about over okay
welcome reading those books okay well no
China hasn't been a very fair player but
all right no no I know I know but I've
been reading I've been reading this book
on John Adams it's fantastic it's uh he
was I didn't know that he was the lawyer
that represented the British soldiers
for the Boston Massacre did you guys
know I didn't know that I didn't know
try I didn't know that actually I think
I did I read that once there you go what
um
you guys went you're flying a lot today
that's not true yeah boy say Brian's
been lying a little bit today why you
lyin bruh I ever read that book
I told me he told me he's been going on
hikes then we realized that he's lying
cuz corny said well the last time you
went and I and I said he said three days
ago second I said four days ago and then
it turns out it was probably close to
six weeks ago those trails are shut down
this yeah but that's that's an honest
mistake right because sometimes you're
like cuz what happens is the days all
blend in as one so he said I got caught
in a lie I said four days maybe I mean
Papa then you just told him you read
that book but then you never did no no I
didn't read that book but I read that it
was a lawyer for the Boston for this for
the boy the boss millennium okay but
wait baby gorgeous have you been working
out
I haven't I trained hard he's a bit he's
a bit of tummy right now though oh it
doesn't you could both you guys look
like you're in fantastic [ __ ] you look
like you're in fantastic shape he's been
eating a little late at night I've been
eating late at night I don't know it
drugs - I don't some drugs - I did out
of monkey would you wanna hang I mean do
you want out what do you do you've been
seeing your kids you want to hang out I
mean what do you want to do you want me
to drive cross-country no it's all good
I am hanging with my kids but it's no
need I mean whatever you got your
daughter and everything else so that's
fine yeah dude I mean literally man to
protect myself
I've been stickin Clorox wipes up my ass
like the president said and I don't have
Corona okay well good you as soon as
this corona bullshit's over you're
flying to LA and coming on the show in
the house hunt Duda I'd love to come on
the show in house 100% I mean I
sometimes on the zoom I mean it's hard
to get a feel but yah he goes okay don't
throw ham and cheese at anybody I'm just
[ __ ] joking over here in my door I'm
in my I'm locked on my daughter's
bedroom I'm kidding around and go to
your daughter doing right now what
you're doing right now
I think she's outside I think she's
outside in the street okay watching her
nobody I mean this is really our I love
to Chinese I love everyone I truly this
coronavirus you know it sucks right now
but I think it's getting better all the
babies in the room it's it's getting
better and I'm just kidding around I
love everybody
all right well fine I do we see the baby
no no way all right all right now she
ran out she ran out all right dude well
we love you man love you crazy bodies
coming on dressed well done sir thank
you guys love you guys stay for having
me a brother I can't bye Jen bye oh well
well there we are just a stop on Oh
Kristen I'm so funny should we do some
current events I think so we got some
let's go all right here we go okay so a
man in Florida was uh that's fair he was
he was arrested because he was found
with a gun and when police officers came
to his house looking for him he was told
that the reason why the cops are there
because he shoved a woman she then gave
police officers his information to find
him and arrest him for domestic abuse
and when they got there she also told
him the police officers that he had a
gun somewhere and so they found the gun
in his car when they asked him who the
gun belonged to he said it belongs to
his cousin John wick
and later on he then went on to say that
his he made up the name and his cousin
isn't John wick but he did sell the car
to his cousin that's why so he seems
like he's thought things out yeah you
just picked the guy from a movie this
belongs to Captain America
yup what cop is like you say John whit
now how's that Jo HN of Jo Ann he's on
HN Long John wick right was he using
your car as a driver no it's my cousin's
car and it's my cousin's gun my cousins
John wick well that was his whole story
gotcha
alright you don't have a screw head okay
so a couple of days ago the governor of
Kentucky was doing a debriefing and he
was talking about how there were certain
people making up fake aliases and fake
names for to file for unemployment and
he brought up the name Tupac Shakur
apparently he said that they his office
had to look into fake unemployment file
horses and they found someone with the
name Tupac Shakur and they assumed that
it was somebody putting out a fake name
a couple days later the governor came
back out and said that he had to
apologize because Tupac Shakur was an
actual person real person yeah
somebody's name is [ __ ] Malik Shakur he
changed his name after Tupac died and so
he came out and said no I'm a real pro
does I'm hurt I'm really embarrassed in
shock Shakur Alda are you yeah he's a
pause oh that's just my name huh but you
know someone government the governor of
Kentucky came out and actually
apologized him personally and it's not
cool it's all good don't be that
sensitive and also that's totally
understandable
I wonder if those pictures up there
you're probably not gonna find Tupac
Malik [ __ ] no Will Smith wife was uh
dating two vodka a long time she was
denied those rumors it's weird like they
grew up together and everyone kind of
does because she sound yeah she says
that
they were more of a like he was more of
a brother figure to her but everyone's
kind of like come on to Boston I haven't
friends are hanging around okay so a
reporter for Good Morning America set up
his home office to make sure that he can
do his segment and he decided not to
wear pants and he did like his webcam in
a way where you would basically just
like Chris where you would only be able
to see his torso but there was an issue
so you see this little blue area right
here that's covering where like you
would be able to see him from the torso
down not wearing any pants if that
little blue bar was gone he thought it
was gonna be there the entire time
I want to disappeared people then
realize like he wasn't wearing it just
put pants on so funny he said he didn't
want to wear pants because he was gonna
work out shortly after there did you see
oh I should have sent to you Brody
instead did you see that guy he's a he's
a chin he's a Spanish he's a Spanish guy
on a news network and he's talking and
then his sidepiece runs in the aian yes
they're both journalists even the girls
journalist and she's married oh he goes
with like Nick oh yeah it's great
he's there on panties let me see that
she's super hot really yes I feel like
all Spanish journalists are smoking have
to be I said he should have freaked out
like it's a [ __ ] rock yes ma be right
back what's a [ __ ] rock peak she's
born that's yeah you got caught dude
don't get calling that well he didn't
mean to is the dub si walk behind the
camera I know you could hear him talking
so she must know these on some sort of
interview she said well you just think
so he's gonna have our stuff
yeah I think you was a car like he was
already in a separator or going through
some sort of separation but then this is
still a bad lawyer say yeah I don't know
you should free done pretend there's a
race pain by the way they'd be like
Spain there's like come on what else you
get then let's see what's a good one
here okay you'll like this
Oh was that Mexico or Spanish si double
a let's go well they said it hasn't gone
into effect yet but it's going to happen
there are a lot of athletes to make my
oh isn't this weird because in the
corona stuff and they gotta extend the
season and the universities have to have
make their money cuz only about money
that's where these universities stay
open you know okay we're gonna pay them
cuz now it proves that it's all about
money the only thing they do is for
money so they want to do this delay the
season have the kids play take a month
off then we start the season it's insane
because the universities need the money
so it's kind of a good thing you know
there's some positives out of this
corona [ __ ]
yeah so this suffering decades that's
diggin and badly in court launching
advertising campaigns or just shaking
their collective head no the
n-c-double-a Board of Governors has
agreed to provide its athletes the same
economic freedom as any other students
on campus Sarge January 2 in 20th place
it still must clear a vote
we proved like state to receive
compensation for third-party
endorsements Oh
namely if you can make a buck and go
make a buck so your likeness so we're
not gonna give you the money but if you
get else yes that's at least it's a step
and I should start it's basically like
oh yeah we're you're not getting giving
you our money that we're making millions
off you but for the one or two kids who
can get a Nike contract yeah there you
go do that how would you work as pay
scale though cuz if you have kids there
some kids don't start for example the
starters make more money oh yeah
the the the second-string gonna make the
same money as the stars in the NFL why
would they make the same money the
women's volleyball team should make as
much money as that the [ __ ] football
men's football team generates the I'm on
the starters and the special kids who
sell take it you know
it's so [ __ ] up dude all right this is
this is tough because how many those
kids can get actual [ __ ] endorsements
least they can now not get screwed by so
small step in the right direction mainly
just basketball players that's basically
just for basketball players all right
this is not a huge deal here for the
show but Kristin Cavallari and Jay
Cutler got it I was surprised I worked
with her at E and she's a smoke yeah
she's really hurt yes even prettier in
person on the show and she was on ice
from the hills right the hills of Laguna
abode a beach but so initially I said
that he was cheating but I guess whether
he live you have to say something like
someone's at fault so she put Maryland
misconduct in order to get a divorce you
have to show fault uh so no that's not
true cuz when you do you can say
irreconcilable difference she did that
but then you also have to show fault in
this particular area there's a Chicago I
think George or something Tennessee at
fault state well my guess is he may very
well is what it is but your guess that
would be my guess what would you say if
Ida come here well no that's that's what
people are saying but yeah but didn't
they say but they're saying it's not
about another woman yeah that's what
they're saying the insiders who knows I
knows what's going on yeah cuz there was
rumors that shoot that he hooked up with
her best friend yes yes those are though
under Sun hmm really
yes that's Anna you said he's really
funny right like you watch the shown you
know they like barely had him in but
then you found out more people tuned in
for him cuz he's really funny
interesting the surprise star of the
show I didn't really watch I just heard
that yeah she's a smoke show f four kids
together five o'brien wife's 90-day
fiance and got sucked in yeah head with
no neck
I felt so bad I don't die I feel
terrible for the black lady who's being
catfished by a guy in England oh she's
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] but she's just
lonely
she still she's an idiot she's lonely
but she's so desperate that she'll
believe that I just felt this so Mac
sent her death threats and they send out
her sexy pictures and stuff like that
have you gotten there no spoiler this
guy's this guy it's all fake yeah he's a
piece
but she's so stupid for threats well
saying like if they don't if she doesn't
send him a certain mount of money he's
released the sexy pictures and she's
like his account got hacked and her
daughter's like no didn't this is him
this is a guy and then it was a picture
of him and then it changes another
avatar she's like this is all fake she
still won't believe it that you can't
fix stupid dude speaking of that guy ed
I went through his Instagram just to see
ed with no neck what happened with that
relationship spoil that for me uh I
think she took off I don't know yeah I
think she realized he had no neck and
left I just saw this video of him I
guess it was filmed a few days ago his
neck stretched out the helmet and with
the chin strap and I just thought so
funny he's not riding a bike nice day I
ran out of water so I'm gonna go to the
water lady she's on University but I
wanted to show up my cool Vespa now
that's fine Brennan the guy who marries
the Russian girl who lost his little
baby what happened with him I don't know
the gem of the one Russian girl that
never shows up
oh she hasn't show up no no just like
four times now that's the guy that's the
dorky I'm talking about the muscular guy
from all the most guy I don't know what
happens then but do you found out that
he went to he was in prison for drugs
and has to tell the family and the moms
like oh no he'll know you went to prison
for selling drug I who's got two kids I
think so you went to prison I think
that's Nashville or something okay you
like it might be a yeah what about his
past he had a past I said yeah he went
to a prison for selling drugs I don't
have to fit for you have to tell him he
gives a [ __ ] that you're a kid we're
like 23 yeah but you had kill him again
though and this trench drop is
interesting all right so you you talked
about you guys talked about that guy
Devin Booker before he has a huge hog
you said from MBA the biggest well it
looks like he's dating kendall Jenner no
they were spotted who was he dating
kendall Jenner the supermodel out of the
Kardashian family is datin BJ Simmons
with their kind
this is at a rest stop and Ismay Bock
yeah these are super baller my cockatiel
really apparently the biggest right yeah
how do you go where'd you hear this from
let's just that mean that's just
congratulations water cooler talk well
done sir Baby Bop moved they don't make
them anymore there are so nice though
they're cool this is a a bunch of German
doctors this is their way of protesting
that there's a shortage of PPEs right I
thought this is a joke they really are
yeah so they're doing naked photos as
their protest because they don't have
enough equipment and then some of these
pictures are interesting too like this
guys these are all doctors that's really
really interesting we got this guy right
here
no like Holocaust survivors they look
very very creepy I will say that yes
these like weird hostage photos like
they made them take those pictures yeah
yeah it looks very stages strange it's
so creepy
mmm this is their way of trying to get
Matthew some you know to make a point
like they don't have enough equipment so
they're they're pretty much naked
they're saying terrible point there's
just a bunch of bad bodies yeah and
they're all doctors too this is a shock
this guy Irfan Khan Slumdog Millionaire
actor no he's interested park he was in
there too he passed cancer dr. Katz 53
huh [ __ ] you young man my age he's
killing it too in the movies damn he
just passed away from cancer
yeah there's suddenly two more what kind
of cancer pancreatic or something um you
get a rare neuroendocrine tumor that's
such a shame : only the weak that's such
a shame
was he a Bollywood star too yes and then
he crossed over here and became a huge
star here huge yeah he's got a hundred
and fifty Bollywood and Hollywood
credits to his name Wow yeah that's the
sad news of the day um you guys know
about this so Joe Biden has a sexual
assault allegation against him and
alyssum
no like back when Cavanaugh was on trial
she said you have to believe all women
all right and then finally now that her
friend Joe Biden has allegations she's
like let the you know what the process
of the legal process began we don't know
so she's getting trashed online of
course how long ago was this woman was
this incident she was 29 when it
happened and what was this about what is
she saying he did he pulled her aside
and then he digitally raped her like he
put his fingers inside her and then she
said she didn't want anything and he
goes what I thought you people told me
that you liked me and now I was supposed
to be heard that's a her allegations I
was in miscommunication and if you see
Joe Pyne talking about this assault
easily as miscommunication I've never
heard of Milano - that's a second but
this is we don't know right I mean I'm
not a fan of Biden but we don't know we
know her actions all right
Oh Alyssa Milano yeah I'm saying but I
like her she said - bummer
she's saying well hold on let's take the
process do it but before she was like
you we gotta listen every woman has
technique - no she wasn't after a guy
she likes yeah a Democrat no no we got
listen no no no same energy you had a
few years ago right that same energy
from two years ago where was that yeah
that's right and I think all of us know
that no matter what but due process
let's see what's happening that's that
hey be careful do posture
I ain't winnin [ __ ] dude whether this
happens not evolve women this is
different well if you're gonna put
yourself out there like that you're
gonna have to take your thing yeah this
is the newer I know if it's written here
but the newer thing is like that girl
that's saying the allegations are true
she said that I guess other people came
out to prove her point see like she
reported it before and then when someone
that knew him also knew about it I was a
long time ago all these politicians do
grab people other poses well well they
definitely are maybe maybe not I don't
know yeah I believe it do you know yeah
older dude young girl grabbed it by the
[ __ ] it's going just crowded two rounds
definitely did it I mean yeah there's
another thing here too
Bill Clinton did it so if JFK didn't
slip a few digits inside butthole
well I think that there are a lot of
cases where women knew they didn't have
any recourse you could we go back we
gotta tell ya right so that girl that
that's accusing Biden she said there's
an actual recording of her mom on Larry
King show in the 90s where she says
something similar like you know I my
daughter has is working for a very very
powerful person we don't know how to
report it this NAT and it was recorded
on Larry King show it was like hearing
like thank you very times like this man
I know he's old just being in Hollywood
as long as I have the stories I've heard
that happened to regular gals with
famous people mm-hmm and they couldn't
say anything that that's a fact that if
you you know what to do if you're a
regular dude and watch just watch
entourage and watch how just watch on
trust that was 10 years how long ago is
that 15 years ago let me see what you
never thought there was anything
different it's like oh [ __ ] maybe there
was something back a couple more phone
calls on this very important topic our
guests are former United States Senator
Howard Baker Richard Allen former
national security adviser and Louis
Romano of the water you know when Joe
Biden goes I don't remember
i legit think he doesn't remember that's
possible I'm wondering what would you do
besides go to the press in Washington my
daughter has just left there after
working for a prominent senator and
could not get through with her problems
at all and the only thing she could have
done was go to the press and she chose
not to do it out of respect for him or
she had a story to tell but out of
respect for the person she worked for
she didn't tell her but these are the
people who do come to the Louis Romano's
right the staff worker who says I want
to let you know about what's going on
guy down the hall their King was doing
the damn thing anyway it's 1993 yeah
damn so there's there's people backing
up the story that's why that's pretty
damning so that's what I listen to lies
I look at I've heard about the recent
stuff about her mother calling in
because it was that matter mamas if
you're a parent but that's the most
recent thing I think she wrote just me
too
no [ __ ] that's interesting knowledge
you have to Train I don't mean color
[ __ ] she's a friend
okay this was on this this was on I saw
this on ESPN's do people keep tagging me
really what the [ __ ] is this this guy's
like big boy thick boy goals I don't
know if I'm ever get this level know or
did you too thick for this looking guy
Killian Ryan this is a professional
mountain biker I check him out look
riding on this cliff these are previous
newzealand chapter right are you [ __ ]
joking me and fall off it's game set
match
he's on one's a wheelie when he's
wheeling it he's off see a pro oh my god
up fro yeah yeah oh my [ __ ] god yeah
well this is where the bike becomes
exactly like your feet there's just no
difference I mean that's so [ __ ]
crazy
mm-hmm he's going dude
one little slip what the [ __ ] yeah
absolutely no he's is Christ why in the
actual [ __ ] is going on
that's so man insane that's insane
that's insane that's there's no reason
to do that this is if you're that good
you that good ah someone sent this in to
me Fred's name but this is the coolest
clip I've seen so far of that animal on
a prey a little squirrel mm-hmm and that
Bobcat is trying to eat it
girl chill out see it there find a game
right now what's gonna luck who's gonna
live that's a life yeah a game who's
gonna live yeah that's gross gotta be
very you can't go to high
mm-hmm and he can't take off Kenny but I
would think you would the scroll just go
hauling ass you know look at this holy
[ __ ] that Bob guess
[ __ ] dude oh damn that's got him amazing
right
you know what he deserves that [ __ ] you
God I'm not the scroll was gonna get
away - I did think that's good damn hey
get away from a cat that's too big shell
too fast too fast
holy [ __ ] - athletic that was cool man
Wow
that's from nature is phenomenal nature
is phenomenal Wow man you're the
squirrel and I'm the guy Wow hick boy
don't camera know you'd be the squirrel
dude his cats bigger and a little tiny
squirrel oh look at the old squirrel
yeah not much meat on this one wait
remember that video we posted when I was
the [ __ ] deer and you were the line
we did have Instagram why I'm like ah
[ __ ] hey Ron yeah so stupid that it Jim
that's it
that's a good one guys well we did it
another bonus episode is episode
quarantine bonus not a boner episodes
quarantine boners quarantine boner
episode guys thank you so much for
tuning in with love you stay rock-hard
family won't you set us off button this
the fun kid we're out
so Chris what's up baby oh yeah dude
hell yeah just go time a little lower
yeah zoom in yeah Wow